The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
Hi, I'm Jocelyn, and we're going
to go over Fall 2009,
Exam 1, problem number 2.
So as with every problem,
we want to first
read the full question.
In box notation, give the
complete electron
configuration of each of the
following gas-phase species:
calcium 2 minus and
magnesium 4 plus.
So the first thing to note here,
is you need to know what
electronic configuration is.
If you don't, you might want
to go back and review that
material, but it is basically
assigning
electrons to orbitals.
The next thing you need to know
is what box notation is.
And Professor Sadoway introduced
that in class, and
you'll see, as I go through
this, a refresher of that, if
you forgot.
So to assign electrons to
orbitals, we first need to
know how many electrons we have.
So let's start with the
first part of this problem,
which is calcium 2 minus.
We will look at our periodic
table, and see that neutral
calcium has 20 electrons.
So calcium with no charge
has 20 electrons.
The 2 minus tells us that it
has 2 extra electrons.
Right?
Because electrons have
a negative charge.
So we have a total of 22
electrons that we need to
assign into orbitals.
In order to actually do the
assigning, we need to follow
the three rules that Professor
Sadoway introduced in class.
So I will put that over here.
The first rule is that you need
to fill them, at least
for a ground state species, in
order of increasing energy.
That is, you want to fill up
the lowest energy orbitals
first, and then move to the
higher energy orbitals.
This makes sense because ground
state species want to
have the lowest total
energy possible.
So the first is--
Now, how do we figure
that out?
Well, there's a few ways.
One way is a nice trick that you
can do on the side of your
page or something.
And it goes like this.
So we have our s, p,
d, and f orbitals.
Right?
We know that s can be in the
first energy level up.
We know that p starts at the
second energy level, d starts
at the third, and f starts
at the fourth.
The tricky part is that you
don't just fill up 1s, 2s, 2p,
3s, 3p, 3d.
There's a little bit of mixing
up of the energy levels versus
the actual energy
of the orbital.
So a nice side of the page
trick is to draw diagonal
lines down through
these numbers.
And if you follow these arrows,
you'll fill up in
order of increasing energy.
For example, after you fill up
the 2p, you're going to fill
up the 3s then the 3p, the 4s,
and then you'll go to the 3d.
If that doesn't make sense,
you might want to go and
review a little bit about the
orbitals in your textbook, or
other resources.
The other way you can think
about the ordering of the
energy of the orbitals,
is to be familiar with
the periodic table.
So we're just going to have
an aside over here.
And a general, very rough sketch
of the periodic table
would look something
like this.
OK?
You have your alkali, alkali
earth metals over here.
You have aluminum, oxygen.
Your halides, your noble
gases over there.
But the way I drew it here is
in what we call blocks.
So this is your s block, and
then we have our p block over
here, d block, and the the
f block is down here.
So once you get more familiar
with electron configurations,
you can actually looks towards
the periodic table, and know,
depending upon where your
element is in the periodic
table, what its electron
configuration is.
Or at least the electron
configuration
of the valence electrons.
OK.
So moving back to our trick,
which we'll use now, we know
that we have 22 electrons, and
we know the order that we need
to fill the orbitals.
So let's start writing out our
boxes, which is how Professor
Sadoway wanted us to answer
this problem.
So we have 1s, our 2s, 2p.
If you're unsure why I'm only
drawing 1 orbital for s and 3
orbitals for p, again, you might
want to go review that
beginning orbital material.
So we filled, we have 1s, 2s,
2p, 3s, then we're going to do
the 3s here, we're going
to do the 3p.
And after the 3p, we do
the 4s, and after the
4s, we do the 3d.
Which has 5 boxes, right?
So now that we know which
orbitals we're going to fill,
we need to know some more rules
about filling them.
So the second rule, over here,
is the Pauli exclusion
principle, which says that no
two electrons can have the
same quantum numbers.
For us, that means that we
basically can only have two
electrons per orbital,
and of opposite spin.
So that's something we need
to remember for this.
The third is Hund's Rule.
And that is, we want to
have as many unpaired
electrons as possible.
So that will come into play
when we're filling up our
boxes in just a second.
If these are confusing,
again, we want to look
at the lecture material.
So I forgot my boxes here.
Now let's start the fun part of
filling up the elections.
So we fill up 1s, spin
up and down, the
2s, spin up and down.
So that's 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15,
16, 17, 18, 19, 20, and
we have 2 more.
So in the 3d, we're going
to do 21, 22.
And I separate them out because
of Hund's rule.
We want to maximize the number
of unpaired spins.
They both spin down, or both
spin up, but they will be the
same spin, and they will be
in different orbitals.
So this was the answer for
this part of the problem.
Now let's move to
the second part.
And maybe you can try by
yourself, and then
we can do it here.
All right.
Now we're going to do the second
part of this first part
of the problem number 2.
So it asks us for the electron
configuration in box notation
of magnesium 4 plus.
So again, we're going to
determine how many electrons
we have. Which, neutral
magnesium has 12 electrons.
But the 4 plus signifies that we
have 4 less electrons than
neutrality, and so we subtract
4, and we have 8.
With 8 electrons to work with,
we again want to write down
our boxes using the energy level
tricks that we have. And
now we can fill them up.
The Pauli Exclusion Principle
tells us 1 spin up and 1 spin
down per orbital, and Hund's
rule tells us that when we
fill up this 3p, we're going to
try to maximize the number
of unpaired electrons, and then,
when we have to, we pair
up the spins.
So that's another main mistake
that people make, is they pair
up too many spins, violate the
Pauli exclusion principle,
putting 2 electrons of the same
spin in one orbital, or
something of that nature.
So this again is the correct
answer, and would-- oh!
I'm sorry.
This is 2p.
I'm sure you guys caught that.
And would have awarded you
full points in this part.
All right.
Now we're going to start
the second part of this
problem, part B.
So first we want to read what
the question is asking.
Give the chemical identities
of the species with these
ground state electron
configurations.
So now we're working in the
opposite direction.
In part A, we were given a
chemical species and asked for
the electron configuration.
Now we are given the electron
configuration, and asked for
the chemical species.
So the first one has
the electron
configuration of xenon.
So this is a noble gas
configuration, plus what turns
out to be 27 electrons.
One way you can do this, is to
go to xenon, which is in the
fifth row of the Periodic Table,
and count through 27
electrons, remembering that when
you get to the d on the
sixth and seventh row, you need
to go to the f block,
which is signified in
this problem by
having f block electrons.
Count through the f block,
the d block,
and end up at thallium.
Or if you are familiar with the
Periodic Table enough that
you can recognize the valence
electrons are in 6p.
And the 6p only has one
electron in it.
So that tells me, xenon
is in row 5.
This element is going
to be in row 6.
I go to the first column of the
p block, which signifies
that there's one electron in
that 6p orbital, and I see
that it's thallium.
That's the quicker
way to do it.
On an exam, you might want to
be that familiar with the
periodic table to be able to
do that, because you're
certainly time-crunched,
a lot of times.
So because that's a neutral
atom, that method will work
very easily.
The second part is a little
trickier, because it has a
charged species.
So we have a net charge
of 4 plus, an electron
configuration of
argon and 3d5.
This may seem a little confusing
at first glance,
because we always fill
the 4s before the 3d.
But when you're ionizing an
atom, it turns out you take
electrons from the 4s
first, even though
it's of lower energy.
So that's a little subtlety
that's not too important to
this problem, but it may have
tripped you up when you were
looking at this, and certainly
caused some problems for the
people in this class.
Again, we go to the periodic
table and we see where argon
is, and then we go
to the next row.
The way I like to think about
this, is this is the electron
configuration, missing
4 electrons.
To find the element that has
this charge, I'm just going to
add back in the electrons, go
to that position in the
periodic table, and that is
my elemental species.
So we want argon plus, instead
of 5 electrons--
I'm sorry, the problem
says this is a 3--
instead plus 3 electrons, we are
going to go to argon plus
7 electrons.
And going through the periodic
table, you'll see that that
leaves you with manganese.
Adding the 4 plus, because that
is part of this chemical
identity, we get the answer
of the problem.
So again, the charged species
make this a little more
complicated.
The easiest way is to go back
and add in the missing
electrons, because that is your
chemical species, and
then remember to signify that
there actually is that charge
for your answer.
So moving on to part C, it asks
us, write the quantum
numbers of one of the
3d and one of the 4s
electrons in iron.
So this requires a knowledge of
what quantum numbers are,
and what values they can have.
So let's start with the 4s,
because that's a little more
straightforward.
He tells us that we have an n
quantum number, l quantum
number, m and s.
And, hopefully, we all know
that n is the principal
quantum number.
It's basically your
energy level.
l gives you what type of
orbital you're in.
Right?
If you're in the s,
the p, the d.
So it just tells you your
orbital shape, basically.
m gives you the angular
identity of the
orbital you're in.
We didn't really talk
about that in depth.
We just need to know, it tells
you which of the p orbitals
you're in, or which of the
d orbitals you're in.
So I'll say, which orbital.
And the s is your spin.
Right?
So for a 4s electron, it doesn't
actually matter what
the identity of our
species is.
So that he tells us is iron is
kind of extra information.
A 4s electron already has 3 of
its quantum numbers set.
So we know that n equals 4,
for s, l equals 0, and m,
which orbital, s only
has 1 orbital.
So m always equals 0 for
s, and your spin.
And I'm going to make that a
script, just so it's less
confusing, is plus
or minus 1/2.
So the answer to this problem
could have been 4, 0, 0, 1/2,
or 4, 0, 0, minus 1/2.
Three of them are set
by the fact that
this is the 4s orbital.
The spin can either be
plus or minus 1/2.
If you're unsure of where I
got these numbers, and why
they have to be such, you
may want to review
the lecture on that.
So moving onto the 3d quantum
numbers, we know that n is 3,
l for d is 2, m is negative 2,
negative 1, 0, 1, or 2, right?
Because there's 5 different
orbitals in a d set.
And then again, s can be
plus or minus 1/2.
So picking one set of those,
you could have said 3, 2,
minus 2, plus 1/2, or any
combination of 3, 2, and
the m and the s.
You don't have to get the exact
same answer as your
neighbor or someone else
you're-- well, you shouldn't
be looking your neighbor's
paper, or a classmate, but
these do signify that you're
in a 3d electron.